- I'm declaring, It's Taco Tuesday
here on the Kelly Clarkson Show!
(mid-tempo music)
♪ Taco Tuesday ♪
♪ Tacos ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
(laughing)
I love my band.
I never actually here what's gonna happen
before it happens and
they're the greatest band
on the planet.
I could go on about why I love tacos
but here are just a few reasons.
Tacos are versatile, okay?
Just the other day we made sushi tacos,
here on the show, I know it sounds weird
but you know what?
Don't hate on it, try it.
Not too long ago, we made cocoa puff
and fruity pebble tacos.
That's like a sugar express
taco which I, yes yeah.
I mean you might die but it's good.
(audience laughing)
It's fine.
Plus, tacos are the cutest food,
(audience cooing)
to dress a baby as.
Come on!
She's adorable.
Is that the sour cream?
[Audience] Yes!
(laughing)
It looks like whipped cream.
Which let's make those tacos.
I love whipped cream, okay.
Tacos are also the reason
I have a very special guest
sitting in my audience.
Will my special guest please stand up?
(audience cheers)
It's Danny Trejo everybody!
- Hey!
(laughing)
- Danny!
Thank you!
- Will the real Danny Trejo
please stand up?
Please stand up?
Wait, somebody already did that.
- Thank you for coming.
Thank you for coming today
and sitting in my audience,
it's so awesome.
So what does your shirt say?
Don't be negative, eat tacos.
(audience cheers)
All right well we all
know you Con Air, Heat
and Breaking Bad but in L.A.,
you're also known for tacos.
Tell us about Trejo's Tacos.
- Well, first of all, we've
got seven restaurants,
one donut shop
and we even have a restaurant
right in the airport next to the Puck guy.
The Puck guy?
That guy, what is it?
- Wolfgang?
(laughing)
- Wolfgang!
The Wolfgang guy.
- You know what?
He's never gonna make it.
- That guy.
I got a restaurant.
(laughing)
- I never heard of him.
Well I told everyone,
what I love about tacos.
Why do you love tacos?
Why did you start this?
- You know what?
First of all, tacos are versatile.
Secondly, children with autism
don't do well with gluten.
So we got gluten-free tacos
and we have vegetarian,
vegan, gluten-free.
- I'm not into the first one
you said but yeah.
(laughing)
I'm Texan, I like meat.
- [Audience] Whoo!
- Sorry!
But I'm not sorry, I love it.
You brought some tacos today right?
For us?
- Absolutely.
- Did you bring us all some tacos?
(audience cheering)
- We got tacos for everyone!
- Pass out the tacos, y'all.
Tacos for everybody.
Oh thank you, thank you for my taco.
(laughing)
Oh my gosh!
Okay wait, I gotta try it.
Oh my god it's so good.
- Delicious.
- Thank you so much Danny.